brought to you by watchdogs to hack
everything available in consoles
November 15th and on PC November 29th
hey guys my name is Jess it is November
the 17th and you're changing games what
news
Plus up a new game looks to be on the
way from quantum break and Alan wick
developer remedy entertainment the
studio posted a teaser video today
featuring creative director Sam lake
which says a new game trailer it's
coming soon this isn't the first clue
we've had from remedy as back in August
the developer confirmed that in addition
to working with the Korean developer
smile gate on the campaign for crossfire
2 they also had a secretive project in
the works remedies currently in the
process of shopping a prototype of the
game around two publishers even though
it's currently only in a conceptual
stage in September the studio revealed
that it had started making cooperative
multiplayer games
next up Reysol and CEO Vince Zampella
has said that titanfall 3 is not
necessarily going to happen when asked
if another titanfall game would come out
after titanfall 2 then pellet old Glick
so we don't know yet titanfall 2 is
critically a huge success we're really
happy with all the reviews and the
positive sentiment sales it's too early
to tell we definitely like to tell more
of the story and the universe I think
it's pretty safe to assume that we'll
explore more of it EA publicists Devon
Bennett's clarified that all the
publisher has had to stay on the subject
was that they are committed to the
titanfall franchise so which Zampella
dropped my favorite developer quote of
the week so whatever the [ __ ] that means
finally take two CEOs Trousdale nick has
talked Red Dead Redemption to speaking
at an MK n partners event Zelnick begun
by commenting on the release of the
first game explaining the conventional
wisdom was of course that a Western
wouldn't work we took a different point
of view which is that very occasionally
Weston's captured the imagination of the
public when we launched Red Dead it did
and those times were right for that and
I think the times are right for a big
sprawling optimistic view of America
again and that's not meant to be cute
he added that Red Dead 2 will offer
incredible emotional depth as well as
great story elements and great gameplay
elements specific I know let me know
what you want out of Red Dead 2 in that
comment
books we showed ahead to game spot for
stories on Final Fantasy 15 and Mass
Effect Andromeda ten will be keeping you
company tomorrow so I will see you again
on Monday